get to that in a moment but first I want
to talk about last night last night was
so historic for us
to hear president zielinski it's been a
momentous week for our democracy
yesterday was our height my high honor
to welcome president zielinski of
Ukraine here in the United States
capitol
he delivered a magnificent awe-inspiring
speech I think all would agree and the
courage heroism and determination of
Ukrainian people shown through it was
moving to hear as report on the front
lines of war from what he had just come
from the front lines sharing with us the
Valor
by Citizen and Soldier alike he always
said that people were on the Forefront
of this and the soldiers
came to reinforce it and declaring that
at All Odds Ukraine still stood
I brought this picture because it's one
that I it's one that I show
on Winston Churchill's birthday we have
his birthday party every year just a
couple of weeks ago
we had it in the Rayburn room perhaps
some of you were there and I always show
them the picture of Winston Churchill
speaking to the Congress of the United
States the day after Christmas 1941.
following Pearl Harbor
and my father Thomas D'Alessandro Jr
Baltimore was there and this Arrow
points
and so I always was a source of Pride to
me that my father was there that day
and now a source of Pride that I could
be there to hear another
another heroic
leader of a war a country at War come
ask for help when Winston Churchill came
what he said now think of this and think
of last night he said we are doing the
noblest task in the world not only
defending our hearths and homes but the
cause of freedom in every land
so much the theme
so much the common purpose
of president zielinski
but I'm so proud of this and when I
wrote to the members about coming I said
I take great pride in my fact that my
father was there for that let I hope
that your children will take pride in
the fact that you will be present for
president zielinski so I was very proud
of the turnout that we had even though
it was the last minute notice because we
could not notice unless we knew for sure
the president was coming
depending on what was happening in
Ukraine depending on weather and the
rest again
democracy online
what honor it was to have the flag that
was presented to president zielinski by
the troops
by the troops and he and they asked him
to bring it to us to say thank you
um we don't have it here but we're gonna
having it framed so you'll see it in the
halls of Congress for a long time to
come but thanking the Congress of the
United States and the American people
for their support
signed by the soldiers of course they
thanked the president of the United
States and we're very proud of his
leadership in all of this
we gave him a flag but he said I'm
bringing you a fly that's well I'm
bringing your flag and so we gave him a
flag and the latest manifestation of the
unshakable relationship between our two
countries
this week was also marked by a focus on
Democracy here at home today the world
will see the final report of the
bipartisan select committee to
investigate January 6th after eight
months 18 months of
tirelessly defending democracy We Salute
Sherman chairman Thompson I just did in
the caucus and vice chair Liz Cheney and
all the members of the committee for
their persistent patriotic leadership
uh 117th Congress began with a violent
assault on our democracy
and now we hear its conclusions we have
a vital road map and ensuring Justice is
will be done and keep and that this
won't happen again and keeping with our
special focus of the week
these excellent work this is this is an
enormous undertaking the Omnibus package
take strong steps to defend democracy
included in legislation another round of
security
economic and humanitarian aid for
Ukraine as president zielinski said last
night this money is not charity it is an
investment in Global Security and
democracy
indeed it is a worthwhile investment and
our bipartisan bicameral support must
continue because the battle for Ukraine
is a battle for democracy itself
also in the Omnibus and this is pretty
exciting for all of us uh
we're addressing some of the um
vulnerabilities in the January 6 attack
by reforming the Electoral count act we
will throw it future attempts to
undermine the peaceful transfer of power
and thanks to Democrats numerous
negotiating the negotiating on this you
know the bill is the Appropriations Bill
and that is what keeps government open
and meets the needs of the American
people in the Appropriations Committee
probably bigger than that are the
provisions in the bill we call it Ash
and trash just as a
and that does remarkable things and we
had tremendous success with that in fact
the highest in terms of Appropriations
the highest um domestic non-defense
domestic number ever we always want more
but nonetheless
and again thanks to the tenacious
negotiating Rosie to Laura was a maestro
it is a maestro I mean just tough
negotiator but a maestro
the Baton and a stick
we've secured significant increase
heavily invested in families and workers
under the commitment to our veterans
and strengthen democracy at home and
abroad most people don't know that
veterans fall under the domestic agenda
it is a consequence of War it is a part
of our security but it is not included
in the defense budget so when we're
fighting for a bigger Defense number it
is also to accommodate meeting the needs
of our veterans and we want to honor
them every chance we get and this year
The Pact Act of something historic and
um
needs to be funded that will take some
more time but we do have funding in this
bill for it too so I hope the Senate
will swiftly pass this package again my
delay related to how we see what will
happen there on certain amendments when
we would get the bill how much time it
takes once it's passed to come over here
I know you're interested in schedule so
that's why I'm going to be more specific
in the details There Our Hope would be
that if it was
finished this afternoon it takes us
about five hours to get the bill we go
to rules we could pass it
tonight that would be our hope
but um shall we say
waiting to see how long the debate goes
there
we want people to be able to go home and
as you know there's storms Across
America and hopefully that will be a
motivation
for
expedited a discussion uh there or just
submitting for the record or saving it
for another day or whatever
as you know this is my this I thought
last week might have been but this is my
final weekly press conference and some
of you have been covering Congress for a
long time others are new uh all of you
are guardians of democracy you've heard
me say again and again if there were one
freedom and the First Amendment the
freedom of of the press that would be
the one that protects and defends all
the other freedoms our Founders knew
that freedom of the press is
foundational to government of by and for
the people and forming the public about
the work done in their name in this case
here if you know as I admire your public
service I always enjoy our conversation
uh turn to San Francisco Sports
49ers younger one yellow Warriors orange
Giants I wish I owe you and all of your
loved ones a happy holiday and you're
the last questions
so from the time the Senate passes it
it'll take five hours well it takes a
number of hours it is to get to the
house
so you you that'll be until we have uh
the bill we cannot signal a rules
committee right the rules committee
needs an hour's notice and then we hope
that it would not be a long Rules
meeting
hopefully we could get expedited
procedure in that hour of notice and
that we could just move this even more
quickly
when you do the bill just so you know
this because I'm an appropriator and I
take great pride in the work of
procreators
after after you have the bill so we have
a bill okay now they may amend it and
we'll see what happens but when you have
the bill
you
sit side by side and come read
everything in it
so that it is what is being written in
the parchment is exactly what is the
bill that takes a long time for
thousands of pages
then and when
that was finished and we get the signal
from the Senate that they want us to
send the bill you go to the senate floor
and it's a beautiful thing you go over
to the Senate and you take Section by
section by section by section else and
Senate not as long as reading every word
but confirming the sections what is that
called it has a name but it is
so all that is done now it's just a
question of the Amendments you know what
many of them are probably 15 maybe
four to six have a chance to be passed
other compromises made
and uh
question of how long people decide to
chat to talk on the floor we would hope
that it with this smaller amount of
amendments it would come over sooner be
closest to what we
sent we sent over so again in terms of
your planes I think it's tomorrow
but it could be tomorrow morning is what
we hope yes ma'am Madam speaker thank
you for your comments um I just want to
ask you in this time of transition have
you had any conversations with leader
McCarthy or do you intend to and if he
prevails as Speaker what advice would
you give them well I don't think anybody
needs any advice from anybody you've
heard me say even about our own
distinguished leadership I'm not going
to be the Mother-in-law comes in and say
this is the way my son likes his turkey
stuffing his scrambled eggs or anything
else they have to have their own
Vitality about it all and they do and so
as far as he is concerned I am
yes we we have some we have had a formal
conversations but we're we interact and
um I'm just hoping that on January 3rd
that they'll be expeditiously able uh to
elect a speaker so that we can get on uh
with the work of the Congress
and um just so you you know this may
interest you what I have said to
everybody is
the hardest thing that I had to do
since you're asking this question
I was speaker
and minority leader under President Bush
under President Obama
under what's his name and there's just
speaker under President Biden but of
three different role three different
presidents two different roles
the hardest thing that I had to do
and all of that say let's just talk
about the the three the hardest thing
that I had to do and I said this
in friendship and in love and all the
rest of that is
when we had a Democratic president
and we were in the majority minority and
we were in the minority as minority
leader to sustain a presidential veto
because the Republicans would roll out
stuff that sounded like
a chocolate sundae but it's more like
doggy do
but it looked good and it played well in
districts and people say oh this is good
no it ain't good it's terrible it
undermines Affordable Care Act we have
to sustain the presidential veto this is
not a casual vote
this is not a casual book so I'd rather
be writing the Affordable Care Act or
any other
massive legislation than to have to go
to my members and say
my friend
in friendship
I really need your vote
to sustain the president's future that
was that was the hardest yeah
about what it's meant for your female
colleagues here about women who might
want to join Congress seeing you as a
person
Trails here I appreciate that question
as well I am
when I came to Congress there were 23
women 13 Democrats
no 12 Democrats and 11 Republicans
out of 435 people
there were 23.
over 400 men and 23 women come on you
know get out of here so some of us just
made a decision we have to change this
we have to recruit we have to fund we
have to encourage
women to run give confidence to them
that not only are they should they be
here they are needed to be here and we
now have 90 Democrats they have 30 you
think something Republicans and they've
made some progress lately and that's
good but we need more
and we need more
people of color and the rest and I take
great pride that our caucus is about 70
percent women people of color lgbtq the
beautiful diversity of America in terms
of women though they're always asking me
and that's I get asked him
what advice do you have I say the best
advice I ever had
that I extend to you is be yourself
you're the only person in the history of
the world who is you
what you have is authentic
is is uh special is unique
and that diversity is necessary at the
table also I want women to have
confidence of sometimes when I act a
little more shall we say
like myself
it's because I want them to know it's
okay
to assert yourself to have confidence in
what you bring to the table and also to
understand your uniqueness so I get I
mean I have overwhelmed by
women telling me how I've given them
confidence or a role model and this and
I said don't worry about any role model
be yourself
seems appropriate that Chad would have
one of the last questions if you don't
think it's appropriate we don't have to
have a look if I bring it up to you in
this democratic form
thank you considering the consternation
on the Republican side of the Iowa
picking speaker as somebody who has been
speaker and has been through speakers
before
does that bother me about what that says
about the stability of the House of
Representatives
and might you be the last speaker for a
while because they pick a student
no I think they'll have a speaker I
think that my interest and all of us
have immense and to the Integrity of the
institution the strength of and respect
that the institution commands and should
command and so that's why I said I hope
that they would be able to resolve their
differences on January 3rd and just come
through with
um uh with a vote to proceed it doesn't
weaken the house it takes a while it
doesn't weaken the house no no we're
democratic institution no I wouldn't
read too much into that but I do
um
but I do think it's
the sooner the better because we have
important work to do whether we agree or
disagree we have important work
activities
yes please
our appropriators that hold billions of
dollars that was in the ndaa for
military defense out of the Omnibus
Appropriations
well the reality Appropriations
well they built the defense number is
bigger than it's ever been
what it is uh I'm not
exactly familiar with that piece but our
commitment to Taiwan is a clear one in
terms of our support for them to be able
to defend themselves uh the um
but to basic first part of your question
this the important purpose in my view of
last night that's why I'm glad the
president spoke in English was to
deliver a message to the American people
of appreciation of gratitude and of
connection in terms of
being about democracy theirs and ours so
it was an important message for our
country
the response that he received
from the members of Congress was
overwhelming it was overwhelming and
that was an important message
for his people for our people to see for
ukrainians to see
the Russians to see and for our allies
to see it was the connection
between our two countries the commitment
to democracy that we associate ourselves
with in terms of the the courage of the
people of Ukraine
I thought you were talking about Russia
yeah China can see that as China can see
that as well that's a holish subject
that's a another press conference for
what whoever uh wants to take that up
but I I as China China
you know I've been on the China case
since Tiananmen Square even before that
I had met with his holy Mr Dalai Lawman
had concerns about treatment in tibetan
that and uh then when Tiananmen Square
came we were more active in terms of the
um
in terms of them the
trade proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction human rights and all that
and the rest of that the
um interesting to see how China
calibrates its activities with Russia
and all of this but I think it was an
important message and isn't it
interesting that December to December
see I invited him October 12th I was
asked why I went to Croatia for a
meeting of something called the Crimea
platform initiative which was about 50
countries represented with speakers to
talk about how we would work together
for democracy in in Ukraine and the
military supported the military effort
at that time October 24th in a meeting
with a delegation from Ukraine they
asked for a joint session best or some
other things too like Patriots but
um
but then of course a question of time
and I have to say
leader of McConnell was so supportive
right from the start right from the
startup that was a real Comfort level to
come back and see the bipartisan
bicameral way uh that we can do this and
and that it would happen in Easter week
when the visit from Churchill was Easter
week excuse me Christmas week the day
after Christmas this a few days before
Christmas is uh is inspiring it's very
inspiring so again it's a message that
is inspirational as well as strong and
informative as to our bipartisan
bicameral support for Ukraine as well as
admiring the leadership
of our president president
the dalessandro family present for
Churchill you knew President Kennedy the
Pelosi family through you serving in the
house through all of this history you
have been in the Democratic Leadership
now for two decades speaker of the house
twice this is a major transition moment
to now move into a different role in the
house your family has long been
connected to could you offer us some
thoughts about how you will approach
your new role in the house in the New
Year both on policy and on your role
with the Democratic party how do you see
2023 for Congresswoman Pelosi well um we
could have a whole seminar on that but
we won't because we're waiting to hear
from the Senate that here's the thing
as Speaker of the House I have awesome
power
as a now transitioning to a different
role I expect to have strong influence
but not on my members just in terms of
encouraging more women for example to
run to
um
to talk about Civics and how we have to
used to be a requirement when I was
little 100 years ago but now it's a
elective and most people are not
familiar so I I'll just see what that
path is
but
the speaker of the house is a very big
job and just wrapping it up will take
time with the Library of Congress for
the papers with the historian of the
capital of the Congress in terms of
interviews and the rest of that and in
just
I think that probably the most
overwhelming thing I'll be doing
forever is saying thank you thank you to
my members thank you to the intellectual
resources that have helped us with
policy thank you for those who've helped
us politically to attain our majorities
and our strength in the Congress
I think my life will be about
accountability to the record the history
and thank you to those who made all of
that possible
dude mention John F Kennedy I'll close
with this you've heard me say it many
times
say it now again because it identifies
with what President Biden has been doing
when I was in school I went to President
Kennedy's inauguration
on the East Front
freezing cold
freezing cold
the whole world every child in America
knows that in that speech she said to
the citizens of America ASK not what our
country can do for you but what you can
do for our country you've said it I see
you all mouthing it the very next
sentence
is what stuck me
the very next sense who is citizens of
the world ask not what America can do
for you but what we can do working
together for the freedom of mankind
that's what President Kennedy said not
condescension not doing something for
but working together
and I've said this to President Biden
and I said it at the St Patrick's Day
lunch because that you know Kennedy
connection there I said to President
Biden
you have
fulfilled
in so many ways what President Kennedy
was signaling working together with all
of the countries to come together to
support Ukraine not by
dictating what we think is the way to go
but to listening working together so
that everybody felt committed to a plan
for the freedom of mankind and that's
how I tie
thing there is my father's daughter at
the inauguration uh to what happened uh
this week
and what our responsibilities are later
but I my goal and my wish is that the
the members that our new leadership in
the house
based on the foundation that we have
laid or forming their own approach will
do even better than the significant
legislative successes that I have had as
Speaker of the House thank you all happy
holidays Merry Christmas Happy Kwanzaa
happy Hanukkah whatever you celebrate
enjoy your family
yes thank you
the San Francisco Giants
did you must comments and fan of the San
Francisco
yeah I was celebrating when he was
coming to the Giant
too much